stepping into your Divine masculinity
freeing yourself from the constraints of
your programming that could be breaking
the chains of a family bond in a
dysfunctional behavior that could be
standing up for yourself at work ending
a relationship that wasn't working for
you anymore these are all initiations
that men are going through all the time
you got to be like I'm done living this
way I'm going to make a change and
that's when we begin the process of
really tapping into our divine
masculinity let's attempt to define the
male the masculine entity in a
relationship it's the mountain the
mountain is Rock Solid it's unshakable
people live on the mountain things grow
on the mountain it's creating this
structure for the divine feminine to
move and grow out of and prosper and
create from